[Music]
I don't think that you are superior and
prohibit teaching on the contrary, having
skills is not a privilege but a
responsibility
[Music]
Hi, I'm Moisés Vázquez.
home with the
costume and arrive disguised until the
university
never
initially the university when I
arrive with this costume as of all
kinds of reactions or people who told me
you are crazy but over time he has
realized that it is an intention a state
and it is part of  the faculty already tell me the
science spiderman
I have seen more connection with the ovum he has to
clarify doubts with the costume
normally I do not show my face in
interviews I think that I am not really
looking for fame that is the important thing not
who does it but who  it's being done
I'm a fan of comics I keep
reading it I keep collecting it I decided to
dress up as spider-man because one
day he comes on public transport
reading comics  s and in a vignette there was
spider-man frank from a blackboard giving
class and I said s it has to be me I would
love for people to see that we
can all do this job always
with more enthusiasm in my case dressing up
motivates me to be a better teacher but
every  who must find a way to
do their job with greater happiness with
greater vocation
[Music]